à peine la balade commencé et les
informations fusent les arbres
grandissent grâce à la lumière surface
foliaire le petit groupe s'engouffre
dans la forêt avec une soif d'apprendre
chen est repeint ces amoureux de la
nature découvre notamment les essences
d'arbres qui composent la forêt c'est un
moyen pour nous de sensibiliser des
jeunes qui peut plus à cet environnement
de l'est de répondre à leurs questions
parce que en fait on se rend compte que
les gens ils ignorent beaucoup de choses
où sont parfois trompé par certaines
fausses informations
souvent on entend les gens qui nous
disent qu'ils sont en train de massacrer
la forêt ils ont tous abattus mais ça
fait partie d'un cycle et de l'entretien
de la forêt le champ intervient
essentiellement pour marquer le
territoire
parce que la plupart des oiseaux sont
très territoriaux sauf ceux qui vivent
aux colonies cette balade c'est aussi
l'occasion pour les participants d'être
sensibilisés aux enjeux environnementaux
les conditions climatiques qu'on connaît
actuellement sont très préjudiciables
pour la forêt et on apprend notamment
qu'il ya des espèces plus vulnérables
que d'autres parce qu'elles ont un
schéma racinaire différent des autres
cette sortie permettent aussi aux petits
groupes d'apprécier les chants d'oiseaux
objectif essayer de les reconnaître même
si les volatiles se font bien discrets
les arbres qu'on y trouve je les connais
un petit peu étendu francs après tout ce
qui est partie oiseaux je connais
beaucoup moins et puis le plaisir de
partager ça c'est première balade on lui
un tel succès que l'équipe
d'organisation a dû refuser des
participants
d'autres sorties seront donc prévue au
printemps